>> Tucker: AT THE STATE OF
MAINE HAS ONE OF THIS COUNTRY’S
LEAST SEVERE CORONAVIRUS
OUTBREAKS.
SO FAR A TOTAL OF ONLY 53 PEOPLE
HAVE DIED.
AS OF TUESDAY ACCORDING TO THE
STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT THERE
WERE A GRAND TOTAL OF 33 PEOPLE
IN THE STATE AND HOSPITALS WITH
CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S OUT OF A POPULATION OF
1.3 MILLION PEOPLE.
ACCORDING TO NEW INFORMATION, WE
WILL BE CONFIDENT THE STATE WILL
NOT COLLAPSE IF IT DOES OPEN
BACK UP AND THAT WOULD BE A
PRETTY GOOD IDEA AT THIS POINT
SINCE ONE IN EVERY SEVEN PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF MAINE IS NOW
UNEMPLOYED.
THAT’S ALL THANKS TO
GOVERNOR JANET MILLS WHO DOESN’T
CARE AT ALL.
SHE JUST ORDERED THE STATE TO
REMAIN CLOSED INDEFINITELY.
RICK SAVAGE HAS HAD ENOUGH OF
THIS AND HE OWNS A RESTAURANT IN
BETHEL, MAINE.
HE SAID HE’S OPENING UP TOMORROW
AND IS DARING THE STATE TO STOP
HIM.
RICK, GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON.
SO I SHOULD JUST SAY AT THE
OUTSET THAT DURING THE COURSE OF
THE PAST COUPLE MONTHS, WE WILL
GIVE AWAY A COUPLE THOUSAND
MEALS IN YOUR COMMUNITY FOR FREE
SO IT’S NOT LIKE YOU ARE NOT
ENGAGED WITH THE PEOPLE AROUND
YOU, YOU ARE.
YOU ARE PLANNING TO OPEN UP IN
THE STATE OF MAINE.
>> THE ORDER ORIGINALLY STATED
MAY 1ST AND WE WERE GEARING UP
FOR THAT.
HE DID WHAT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
DO AND WE CLOSED FOR SIX WEEKS,
COOKED FOR THE COMMUNITY, WENT
RIGHT THROUGH THE WHOLE
RESTAURANT AND REMODELED AND
CLEANED IT AND IT’S TIME TO OPEN
BACK UP.
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH OF THE
PARTS OF MAINE, AND I COULDN’T
FIT PEOPLE IN A 6-FOOT SPACE
FROM EVERYWHERE AND GET OPEN
BACKUP FROM VISITORS.
WE TRIED TO CALL THE GOVERNOR,
AND ALL BUSINESSES ARE MADE TO
OPEN UP AND WE SHOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN SHUT DOWN IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
WHO KNOWS HOW MANY MOTELS UNDER
THEIR BUSINESSES.
SO WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR
EVERYBODY, NOT JUST MY
RESTAURANT.
IT’S TIME TO GO BACK TO WORK.
IF PEOPLE DON’T WANT TO GO OUT,
QUARANTINE YOURSELF.
WE ARE A VERY CLEAN RESTAURANT,
AND I’M GOING TO CHALLENGE THE
STATE TO COME AND SEE, THIS IS
WHAT WE ARE DOING.
IF YOU DON’T LIKE IT, TAKE ME TO
COURT.
AND IF THEY DO TAKE ME TO COURT
I WILL SAVE MY TAX MONEY THAT I
COLLECT THIS MONTH AND USE THAT
TO FIND A LAWYER.
>> Tucker: IT’S THE LAST TIME
I CHECKED, IT’S A STATE, WHAT DO
YOU THINK THE AUTHORITIES JANET
MILLS WILL DO?
YOU ARE ADMITTING THIS ON
TELEVISION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL HAPPEN
TOMORROW?
>> I DON’T TAKE ANYTHING WILL
HAPPEN BECAUSE SHE IS OVER HER
HEAD.
WE ARE BROKE.
SO SHE’S TRYING TO GET FEDERAL
MONEY FROM THE GOVERNMENT TO
BAIL HER OUT SO SHE MAKES THE
STATE LOOK LIKE WE ARE BROKE.
SHE WILL GET MORE FEDERAL MONEY
AND DOESN’T CARE ABOUT THE
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF MAINE.
IF SHE DID SHE WOULD BE REACHING
OUT TO THESE BUSINESSES.
IN THIS FIRST HALF, I CALLED THE
LAWMAKERS AND I SAID IF YOU GUYS
GAVE US BACK TAX MONEY THAT WE
COLLECTED FOR YOU, THE 8% FOR
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY AND YOU
SUSPEND MARCH, WE CAN ALL GET
THROUGH THIS AND IT WOULD BE
REALLY EASY FOR YOU GUYS TO DO.
SOME OF THE BUSINESSES AREN’T
EVEN THERE, AND AS A MATTER OF
FACT I GOT A LETTER A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO THAT SAID DON’T
FORGET, YOU STILL OWE MARCHES
SALES TAX.
>> Tucker: COME ON.
JANET MILLS IS THE MOST
CONFIDENT DICTATORIAL GOVERNOR
THAT I’VE SEEN IN A LONG TIME.